the direction which you're pushing is
that consciousness
is the only fundamental thing in the
universe that
everything else like time all those
kinds of things emerge from that
hey that
what I believe
at this point I I've been saying 50 50
for a long time I'd say now it's like
51.49
in terms of Consciousness being emergent
versus fundamental so I I'm not
convinced of this at all I'm not
convinced that Consciousness is
fundamental what I think is there are
very good reasons to think it could be
and
essentially all of science up to this
point has
been led by the other assumption by the
first assumption that Consciousness
arises at some point namely in brains
and that's where all the science has
gone and I think that's wonderful and I
think it should keep on going and I
actually think that was a more important
place to start but I think there's a
possibility that the correct assumption
is that it's fundamental and so that's
the science I support that's the thing I
spend a lot of my time thinking about
and talking to scientists and
philosophers about and so I I shouldn't
give the idea that I actually have
crossed over into believing this is the
case but it is
it's the Assumption I follow in my work
at this point it's a possibility an
understudied possibility so it deserves
serious reverse attention and there are
good reasons to start with that
assumption versus the other that I think
we're just now starting to realize so
just to clarify when we're talking about
Consciousness we're talking about the
hard problem of Consciousness that it
feels like something to
you know there's a subjective experience
do we
you know if Consciousness permeates all
matter is fundamental
is that going to be somehow
is our current intuition about
Consciousness like
the very tiny subset of what
cautiousness actually is so like we have
our intuitions about personal
experiences like what it feels like what
it takes to eat a cookie or something
like that um
but
that seems like a very specific
implementation of Consciousness in an
organism so how can we even reason about
something that's if Consciousness is
fundamental how can we reason about that
like I'm not sure I'm understanding the
connection between those two things but
when you think about what it's like to
be a plant to experience a thing okay we
can kind of get that we can kind of
understand that there are a lot of
places we could go with this one is
there's actually work being done by
people like David Eagleman he's a
neuroscientist I don't know if you know
him you should talk to him for your
podcast if you haven't he's wonderful
great science Communicator he's someone
I interviewed for my my current project
too
um so he he's done this actually okay
there are many places we can go one is
he does work with sensory addition
sensory substitution and this is
going in some very interest interesting
directions and and maybe partly answers
your question which is giving humans
qualia sensory experiences that we're
not wired for that human beings have
never had before
you let me know what you're most
interested in hearing about but we could
talk about things like the brain Port
um there was actually a study done I
just talked to one of the participants
in the study where they were seeing if
they could give human beings an
experience of magnetic north so other
animals have this
um this sense that that we don't have
where they can feel intuitively the way
that our eyes work to give us an
intuitive sense of our environment we
don't have to translate the information
coming in through our eyes we just have
a map of the external world and we can
navigate it so many animals use a sense
of magnetic north to to get around and
it's an intuitive sense
so I spoke to someone who was in this
part of this experiment
um and it was fascinating to hear him
acquire a sense not only that he had
never had but that no human being had
ever had so when I asked him to describe
the experience
it was challenging for him and
understandably so because it would be
like you describing sight to someone
who's never seen
um but this is clearly possible and
scientists like David Yeoman and others
are working on these and so I do think
it's possible that this line that this
these scientific advancements may
actually start to dovetail with
the Consciousness research in terms of
being able to
experience things we've never
experienced before but I do think that
at some level yes we're limited as human
beings
we may be able to find some proof or
enough proof to at least
assume that Consciousness is fundamental
or you know who knows one day actually
believe that that's the correct
scientific view of things and not really
be able to get our minds around that or
to understand what it means and and
certainly not
to know what it feels like I mean we
can't we don't even know what it feels
like to be other creatures maybe what
it's like to be you
um
yeah I mean I mean that's I guess that's
what empathy is about that's why I tried
to exercise is try to imagine what it's
like to be other people and then you
you're doing that even farther
but perhaps perhaps we can do that thing
more rigorously by connecting different
sensory mechanisms to the brain to do
that for all kinds of organisms on Earth
but they're similar to us in scale and
the time at which they function to time
scale and the spatial scale perhaps it's
much more difficult to do for electrons
and so on some of the intuitions I
talked about I mean I just kind of I I'm
taking them for granted that you and
everyone knows what I'm talking about
but in terms of the science in terms of
the studies
um understanding things like binding
processes understanding just a little
bit about how the brain works and as far
as we understand and then there's just a
ton of evidence now to support that our
conscious experience is at the tail end
of a lot of
um brain processing
yeah so it's just a little bit I mean I
give in the example in my book I I talk
about tennis and The Binding of the
sights and sounds and felt experience of
hitting a tennis ball which in the world
are happening at different times the the
rates
um it takes the sound waves and the
light waves and the the felt sensation
to travel to my brain are different that
there are these binding processes
that happen
prior to the conscious experience that
were essentially delivered to us by by
the brain
um and so we can get we can get back in
into this I can answer your your bigger
question first but I I feel like for for
a lot of people
to understand some of the science that
already
is shattering some of our intuitions
about the role Consciousness plays I
think is helpful in terms of being able
to be open to thinking about these other
ideas